so you've got best film editing on your
Oscar ballot but how do you even decide
what good editing is we've brought
together some editing experts to get
their point of view on their
craft so what is it about editing that
really excites you what what does an
editor do to contribute to the
experience of a film oh we kind of make
the movie in the editing room people
call it the final rewrite of the script
mm editing is building it's creating
it's taking every element all the film
any sound music all of it and creating a
story that holds your attention and
leads you along you've got to first of
all assimilate all that material and go
through it and try to tell the story as
it was originally scripted that's your
guide to begin
with but it doesn't take long to go off
script when you find that certain story
points may or may not connect or for
clarity sake you've got to take a block
of dialogue and just dump it we're
manipulating and manipulating and it
becomes a kind of magical process by the
way we don't do it alone we often you
know hopefully we're actualizing the
vision of the director but we may come
up with ideas that they never thought of
that was never intended as we're on that
journey to make this movie as great as
it can be when you're running through
thousands of feet of film you see a
blink that you love or you see a nod or
you see some one little pieces a moment
a moment while you're running through
these thousands of feet of film and you
remember I think your mind kind of works
like a puzzle you know you're kind of a
master puzzle maker or something and so
you remember these pieces and and you
have to you know a lot of it is the
construction of it and how it flows
together and where your eye wants to go
during the scene you know like oh I I
really want to be in that person's face
where's the closeup and then I my brain
tells me I need to see their reaction
shot and then you remember that piece
you saw and you know and and and it's
finding the right pieces of performances
and weaving all the elements together to
make it seamless the seamless is
actually I guess a very good adjective
although you know one can't help but
react to flashy editing right cuz it's
fun fun it's fun sometimes too
much and by flashy editing you mean sort
of like a lot more Quick Cuts Quick Cuts
or playing with time mhm like a momento
I know a lot of editors sort of Pride
themselves on not being noticed but as
editors I'm sure you notice editing all
the time so what really presents itself
to you as really great editing it's hard
to decide and pick out at something
that's great editing because if it's
great you don't notice it really when a
movie doesn't work I'm in the audience
sitting there looking at every frame of
I can see a piece of dirt go by because
I'm so not involved if you're looking at
films you know that are nominated uh you
know this year and you want to decide
well how do I tell what is what which
one is better than the other they're all
good you might look at how many
different tones are mixed together in
the same film how many different
elements are mixed together does it have
documentary style footage mixed with um
you know standard dialogue scenes mixed
with action and how are those things all
working in conjunction dramatically if
if you were to sort of point out three
things that uh a voter should be looking
for when they're selecting this
particular category what should they be
looking for first that the movie works
that you're not out of the movie at any
point you know when it just flows and
you're completely into it that's number
one and that the character relationships
make sense and uh people do things that
are within their character and uh and
then the pacing seems right for the
material in the movie and also that the
performances are tough Top Notch because
a lot of that is made in the editing
room and all those other things don't
work if you don't have a performance
because you won't believe anything you
won't believe story you won't believe
any of it unless the performance Works K
thank you so much for spending some time
to tell us about your craft it's been a
really fascinating conversation and now
you know a little bit more about film
editing so go to oscar.com and fill out
your my pix game ballot and then share
your predictions with your
friends